this week on wheel of science we're
talking exoplanets
that's the planets of hugs and kisses
right that's what
exactly that chuck
this is wheel of science
everybody i'm chuck nice and welcome to
wheel of science the show where we
answer your questions
about the universe of course i don't
answer your questions about the universe
the one
the only doctor neil degrasse tyson
answers your questions about the
universe what's up neil keep coming back
to my office
stick a camera in my face all i can do
is say spin the wheel
well in that case spin that wheel
[Music]
malcolm mcdougall wants to know this how
will the james webb space
telescope help in the study of
exoplanets
uh james webb space telescope is tuned
to explore and discover galaxies
that are being formed in the early
universe
whose light has been redshifted so
significantly from then
it starts out ultraviolet and blue but
it's so far away
the redshift takes that information
shifts it
into the infrared part of the spectrum
completely across the visible point and
this telescope is tuned
for the infrared to see stuff that was
once
violet and ultraviolet at the early
universe
we'll also get to look deep into gas
clouds
to find stellar nurseries where stars
are being born
would the telescope see planets
transiting a star
in order to see a planet transiting a
star moving the good word truck transit
that's the word we use to see a planet
moving in front of the host
star you've got to take continual images
of it
you got to hang on that object to get
those data
and the kepler telescope recently sort
of turned off
was completely designed to do just that
and the james webb is not designed to do
just that so
you shouldn't think of it as a planet
discovering telescope no
oh kepler poor kepler i knew him well
i love that guy we turned the satellite
off
not the human being he's been dead for
400 years oh my god he's
dead all right neil you ready for
another question
bring it on
chris brolianovic wants to know this
what kind of strange physics do you
think
we could find on exoplanets in other
star systems
there's really no such thing as strange
physics the physics we find here on
earth
applies not only here but everywhere in
the universe we have ever looked
and that was not an obvious fact we had
to sort of
discover that in fact the first person
to find binary stars
in the galaxy two stars say hey they're
orbiting
hey they're following newton's laws of
motion just like we discover here
on earth and the moon and earth and the
sun so therefore newton's laws apply at
least to that distance
then we found binary galaxies then we
found nuclear and
and atomic phenomena going on across the
universe and it all matched
what happened in our laboratory so what
we have found
is that the laws of physics apply not
only across the universe in space
it applies across the universe in time
that enables us to say the laws of
physics
are universal and we mean it unlike
mr universe or miss universe pageant
excuse me
have you compared them to mars anybody
on mars no
it's really mr and mrs earth just let's
make that straight here chuck wow look
at this i just got a text from mr and
mrs universe saying neil degrasse tyson
please
go to hell all right so
the laws of physics remain the same but
what about the expression thereof ooh
how do the laws of physics express
themselves
so uh you can have big planets little
planets rocky planets planets with moons
planets with rings
planets that are icy planets that are
still
forming planets that wanted to be stars
but never made it
we call those brown dwarfs we can have
so there's all there's a panoply of
kinds of stuff
that can form in orbit around a host
star
and we only got a sampling of that here
in our own solar system
the catalog of exoplanets manifests them
all
you know what i call a brown dwarf uncle
luke
all right we're gonna take a break we'll
be right back with more wheel of science
as i contemplate my family tree
stick around thanks wix for sponsoring
this episode
you know i've just got 20 seconds to
tell you how wix helps you to build a
professional or personal site
their website builder is super intuitive
their templates make you look cool and
shiny with almost no effort
everything works automatically for
mobile devices and you can use adi their
artificial design intelligence to get
started right away
yeah i like this head to the link in the
description and start your site today
that's wix.com go slash star talk
welcome back to wheel of science of
course we're here with dr neil degrasse
tyson
neal you ready to do this bring it on
[Music]
all right william pierre ask this
have we found any exoplanets that may be
able to sustain life well
so of the thousands of exoplanets we now
have in our catalogs
of special interest to us are those
orbiting
in the goldilocks zone not too close to
the host star
if it had water it would evaporate not
too far away if it had water it would
freeze
planets that orbit where water would be
naturally liquid in its state
and so we have a sub-catalog
of goldilocks planets that are about the
size of the earth from like half our
size to like
twice our size in that zone so yes
yes in fact we have a earth like
exoplanet index where you combine all
these factors and then you rank them
so the day we ever get to travel across
the galaxy
faster than we currently know how to do
and you wanted to visit
places in order you would visit these
exoplanets in that order
if you're looking for life as we know it
super cool but what about what what
about
trappist the trappist system trappist-1
is a star
that has seven known planets in orbit
around it
three of which are orbiting in the
goldilocks zone
so if you want sort of
a seven for one you want
one trip you get seven planets all in
one once one shopping spree
that's where you would go problem is
taking spaceships that we currently have
invented
and you rode there it would take 300 000
years
to get there that's slightly longer than
your life expectancy
so we need warp drives people get to
work uh
quite frankly i want to take the trip
just so i can keep asking are we there
yet
all right neal you ready for one more
spin that wheel
[Music]
vladimir brutwa wants to know this being
the exoplanets are out of reach for at
least many millennia
why is it important to investigate them
shouldn't we focus on knowing more about
our solar system you never know
how soon somebody's going to invent the
warp drive
it could happen next year not likely
next century
you want to you it's cheap to find
planets you're saying let's focus on our
own planet and on exoplanets it's
telescope time
that's cheap that's cheap exploring the
solar system is expensive because you
got actual space probes
and even that is not as expensive as so
many other things
that we do in life do you realize going
to
saturn with cassini costs less than what
americans spend on lip balm
in a year that yearly budget for that
mission
don't be telling me let's do this not
that let's do it all
i'm sorry neil but my lips are soft and
supple
okay chuck it's your fault we haven't
done five missions that we could have
look at these lips worth it
worth it all right neil is captioned
time
we took a picture of you we put it up
why you keep doing why you
why is it why is this a thing because we
have to give our members an
opportunity to express themselves
creatively and you are the conduit
besides we got over 500
captions all right go on all right neal
here's the picture
and from what i understand you like two
of these
yeah two there's the future's so bright
i gotta wear shades that's a good one
that's actually a uh
a line from a prince movie purple rain
mars day in the time my fuse is so
bright i gotta wear shades i forgot that
because i was thinking of the group
timbuk3
in the late 1980s they had a whole song
called my future's so bright i got to
wear shades
but i got to give an honorable mention
to the caption
this is where we put the extra kneel
when we need him to recharge overnight
that is awesome roomba kneel docking
station and all
it looks like they just slid me into the
slot
and i'm just plugged in ready to
recharge i got that's that's good
that's good it's time for our wheel of
science pull
make sure you answer the poll right here
and the question is
do you think we'll find life on an
exoplanet in the next hundred years
neil well i think
yes because there's a whole cottage sub
industry
of exoplanet research that worries about
biomarkers
these are things no you don't see the
life directly on the planetary surface
but you see their effect on the
atmosphere
of the planet and and
you can't hide that so i think we will
know
one way or another whether a catalog of
exoplanets uh
can where whether any of them contain
life any of them looking at us
they would see sort of runaway smog and
greenhouse gases and
that would tell them there's no sign of
intelligent life on earth
exoplanet earth planet
dummy well look at that we're out of
time and that is our show
as always we have to say thank you to
the one and only dr neil degrasse tyson
thanks neil you're always a pleasure to
be at your service john
god i love the way you lie
until next time i'm chuck nice saying
thanks for watching
before we go i just want to thank wix
from simple landing pages to complex
professional websites
wix has you covered don't need to hire a
web developer
if i was able to build this for star
talk certainly you can build your site
with wix
the editor gives you full design freedom
freedom
it's like that that was my braveheart
wix thing oh never mind they have apps
that let you grow your business they
have unlimited fonts
everything just works it's like magic
no it's like science head to the link in
the description and start your site
today
that's wix.com go slash star talk
[Music]